On the number line
below, which point
more closely represents
the principal root of 43?
Or you could view it as the
positive square root of 43.
And I encourage you
to pause this video
and, just looking at this,
try to approximate where A is
and where B is.
And let's think about
which of those numbers
is closer to the
principal root of 43.
So let's go through
each of them.
So point A right over there--
it looks a little bit more
than halfway along the
way between 6.5 and 6.6.
Halfway looks like
it's right over there,
so that would be 6.55.
So I would estimate A to
be approximately-- A looks
like it's approximately 6.56.
So let's square that and see
what we get-- so 6.56 times
6.56.
And obviously, if
you had a calculator,
you could just punch the
square root of 43 in,
but we don't want to do that.
Or this exercise doesn't
want us to do that,
so I'm not going to use
a calculator for it.
So 6 times 6 is 36.
6 times 5 is 30, plus 3 is 33.
6 times 6 is 36, plus 3 is 39.
Now, you'd think about this 5.
So let's throw a 0 here.
5 times 6 is 30.
Put a 3 up there.
5 times 5 is 25, plus 3 is 28.
5 times 6 is 30, plus 2 is 32.
And then we've got
another 6 here.
Well, we already figured
out what 6 times 6.65 is.
It's 3,936, so let's
throw our two 0's here.
And we're going to have
a 6, a 3, a 9, and a 3.
And now we can add everything
together, and we get 6,
3-- let's see.
9 plus 8 is 17, plus 6 is 23.
And let's see.
2 plus 3 is 5.
Another 5, you get 10.
And let's see.
This is 13, so you get 4.
Let's see.
And you have one,
two, three, four
numbers behind the decimal.
So this gets us to 43.0336.
So this is pretty close to 43.
Without even thinking
about what B squared is,
I'm already
predisposed to saying
that A is going to be
closer, but let's just try.
Let's just think
about where B is.
Actually, we don't even have to
look at B. Because A is pretty
close, and A squared
is already larger.
Let me write this.
So A squared, if we approximated
it right, at 6.56-- so
let me write this down--
squared, which is 43.0336,
is already greater than 43.
Or another way of
saying it, 6.56
is already greater than
the principal root of 43.
So A looks like it's
already-- it's pretty close.
If anything, it's
a little bit larger
than the square root of 43.
So B is going to be that
much-- B is larger than A.
So B is going to get
us even further above.
If we square B, we're going
to get even further above 43.
So we can rule out B, and that
saves us a lot of computation.
And so we're going
to go with A. A is
a pretty good approximation
of the square root of 43.